with that example I would say like I
don't know from the stuff I've heard
from like new couples
um before they move in together into
their new home is before you move in you
have a discussion and negotiate the
house household things certain rules
boundaries things like that so that you
avoid that sort of thing
she was just staying with me oh okay I
thought that's what I'm trying to say
like okay
moving in I think it would be a little
bit different because I'm like okay this
is this is your home too so let's try
and decide together right but she was
just staying with me for a few weeks
okay she wasn't moving in okay and I was
like
it was like oh
um can I leave my toiletries here at
night and she was like oh please I was
like no she's like why I just don't want
you to she was like oh I'll cry I was
like you can cry
wow that's cool that's cool
I had a Russian girlfriend and literally
from the second or third date when I
took a well it wasn't even
um the first date we went around her
place and it was all good but the second
date the first date sorry she went we
walked up to my car to drive to the to
the bar that we were going to go to and
she started critiquing my car because it
was a two-seater convertible and she was
like this car is too small I need a
bigger car I was like this is the first
date then by the third date when we were
around my place she started critiquing
the decor of my place I'm like this is
the third date at least give it a month
before you start changing my life
I wouldn't have got past the first day
out
just take an Uber take an Uber home you
don't like it take an Uber do you do you
think women try to change man
I think I think but it's not always a
bad thing that's that's what I would say
yeah it's not always the benefit some
things are good some things yeah yeah I
think there's a there's a general
Paradox I think women try and change men
and men expect women to never change
you guys are more realistic about what
you have
because of course you'd want like a
Beyonce who's a virgin and and holy and
all that but you can't get that in real
life so you just realistic okay she's
nice she's friendly she's pretty and
that's what you go for so with women
they're not very
realistic about what they want I think
there was like this
um feminist lady she did like a survey
apparently like women had like 385
problems with the men that they dated
whereas men had only like 15 to 18
issues with the women that they dated on
average
that's hilarious yeah
okay I'm not gonna get Beyonce I'm just
gonna get Karen or whatever well they'll
be fine with that well it's interesting
because there's so many girls let's say
like six feet six figures six inches
yeah but there's not men that say that
are average saying I deserve a
Victorious secret yeah because you're
realistic yeah they well I think reality
hits men harder than women we're women
whenever men have a standard they're
tried they're they're shamed for it so
like if they say I want thin chicks
they'll say fat shaming they'll say I
don't want to date a girl that's been
ran through it's shaming where
women if we have a standard we're
praised for it yeah the thing is they'll
Don't Settle yeah
I do have their standards I hear a lot
in the mgtow communities they're they're
constantly going about oh these women is
this and I'm like dude have you looked
in the mirror you've seen who you are
yeah
all these terrible women out there so
sometimes men do have their Onyx on and
sort of outrageous expecting
expectations and I've seen that
especially as I said these mgtow types
who who or even the incels who think
that you know these women are just
terrible I'm like dude you have to fix
yourself and then you'll be amazed how
much can I be honest I think I think
especially like maybe intels and stuff I
think the reason they're criticizing is
because they feel
that they've been criticized a lot and
they feel like they don't measure up so
because it's the same thing like the
same instant model that they're
criticizing if she knocked on their door
you know he's taking her in a heartbeat
second you know what I mean so I think I
don't think it comes from necessary
because they think they deserve that I
think it's more because because they've
given up on The Dating Game they feel
that you know if they're five five and
they don't reach six foot or six figures
all this and because we hear that a lot
that criticism from women a lot I think
they're like okay well if I'm you're if
I'm not you're gonna criticize me for
not being perfect I'm gonna criticize
you for not being perfect well I think
well I think a lot of the problem too is
like average women are rejecting average
man and so it leaves men average men
frustrated because basically they'll let
the like a guy that's at eight nine or
ten will sleep with a four five or six
and so then that girl will think she's
on his level and then the average guy
has to deal with all the baggage at 30.
yeah and so I think that's why they're
frustrated as they're like I'm sick of
the ran through 32 year olds yeah 33 and
now that that would have rejected me at
22 but now they want me because all the
the calm Chads right
all the Chads like
rejected them so I understand where
they're coming from but yeah I mean you
know there's it goes both ways I think
of the way you refer to the opposite
gender kind of says more about you like
if you're the one saying men are trash
men are trash it says more about you
same thing with guys that say women are
women or it's like the
same but it is true that there is this
this phenomena of women in their 20s
They Ride what they call the carousel
there's another term to that as well but
they basically go through all the
different guys in their 20s and then
when they hit the wall in their mid-30s
or early 30s they look for the the two
main groups that in the in the pickup
Artistry sort of game what they call the
the lover and the and the provider now I
myself have always been in the provider
category because I've never had like you
know good looking features in in that
sense so I've always known where I can
where which Pond I can fish in uh but
there's the you know the women go
through all the lovers all the good
looking guys all the bad boys all of
that through their 20s and all the
providers are actually busy with their
head down in programming or or getting a
job or doing whatever and then suddenly
in their 30s these guys when they've
reached a good level of income and
housing and and and sort of well to do
those same girls in the 20s we wouldn't
give them the time of day are knocking
on their door and back in the day there
were a lot of men who would SIM for that
and they were like okay fine I'll take
you even though they know she's been ran
through the whole neighborhood but this
day day and age through the internet and
through a lot of people like Kevin
Samuels
um and actually Pearl you could say she
could be one of those influencers
um they are now changing the game
because a lot of young men are now I
mean I think you've got the stats on how
many of them are virgin they don't
actually they're not engaging in the
dating game anymore because they're like
why should I build all this up make all
this money do all this hard work just to
throw it at the feet of some some
hooters girl who's who ran through all
the guys in the neighborhood in their
20s and now she's knocking on my door so
I'm curious for the girls do you know
what the wall is oh you do yeah okay
it's a very a red pill can you Google
um ish Rolo tomasi um the wall
just in relation to
um the stat you were looking for yeah 70
so if people earn over 70 000 it's five
percent okay so five percent
Nationwide that makes sense Nationwide
yeah